[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when you talk about uh like the 80s and
and being in that La chapter and the the
war with them okay then then the 70s can
you just uh I know this is something I
know you don't want to do it uh you know
it's something that's been sort of
romanticized from people but like what
you know just kind of like walk me
through what that was like be being well
firstly I want to I want to qualify by
saying this
anybody that thinks
war is romantic
whatever type of War they've never been
in a war exactly because it's not
romantic
it's uh it's stressful uh you don't know
uh when it's Gonna Come
uh you know when you declare war on
somebody whether it be on a large basis
as if we're a country going into another
country uh because we don't like their
culture whatever it may be you know uh
of you
you're getting those situations uh that
uh
you never dreamed you would be you know
I uh made some I was a just a member
initially during When The War started
and uh
six months into the war you know there
was already six murders in as many
months a leader of the charter down
there got murdered it was described as
an in-house cleaning by law enforcement
uh you know I've written about it
extensively and you know two of my books
uh
but I became vice president you know I
came in in the middle of a conflict and
I had to try to shift the direction of
what we were doing and what was the
reason for you rising up the way that
you did
old man John who was the leader of
after the
president that took his place John had
been the leader down there old man John
was kind of a legend he was an old man
when uh I was in my 20s you know and uh
I got some pictures I'll send of you if
he's a character he had a really great
picture of him with two pairs of glasses
on this is he's an old school dude he
had regular
like government issue glasses and he
didn't want to have him he didn't want
to spend the money to have uh them
bifocals yeah so he put no he what he
did is he put sunglasses over his
regular glasses because he didn't want
to pay for the tent you know it's too
much money I might waste my money yeah I
just put a pair of glasses over yeah
yeah and I got this great picture of him
looking at his motorcycle with double
glasses on I posted sometimes on social
media and uh you know people like young
guys write me and they go who is this
guy man you know he don't care what he
looks like and I go no man John didn't
care about much yeah and uh so you know
I guess you know he mentored me you know
and it gave me a lot of Sway and he saw
something in me you got to reel and I
just got out of the Marines worked for
the Department of Defense uh had a
structured background and John was
military uh former military World War II
and uh he just put me under his wing and
uh when when the war started with the
Mongols John was very disappointed it
was it's very
convoluted a lot of detail to it but in
a nutshell
uh the war started he wasn't happy he
stepped down was there a specific yeah
we were uh it had been brewing between
us and the Mongols and uh how so well
first of all there was a rumor on the
street that
the Mongols started uh
because we wouldn't allowing Hispanics
in our club which was a complete lie
David Ortega who I met in 1966 and we
were best friends until he passed away
uh you know he was in the question marks
and he was in the Hell's Angels and you
know he was uh Mexican-American you know
Johnny Angel from Oakland you know he
was a Mexican I could go fat Ray I could
go on and on and on so it wasn't true
but you know that
that Vibe was there and uh
probably
the oldest reason in the world was that
one of the Hell's Angels
ex-wife was now living with a Mongol
and we went to a swap meet there was
nine of us it was about 40 to 60 Mongols
and
we met them by accident by accident and
where was the swap meet it was in Santa
Ana and it was the that's a crazy place
to run into somebody yeah so the the I
think it might have been the Great
Western exhibit or something so this all
happened to be there at the same time
same time you know so I was there uh
I got a great story too I was there and
uh
the member whose wife had run off with
the Mongol their eyes met and I looked
at both of them and I knew it was on you
know because I knew the history this guy
was my best friend you know the Hell's
Angels and uh
I uh looked at him looked at uh this guy
Bud who was now living with us and you
know my friend just caught this guy you
could just you know what a saw a perfect
putt sounds like just echoed in there
and uh
it was on you know we got in a circle
and uh they were surrounding us and we
were fighting everyone's fighting
everybody yeah just I mean the Hell's
Angels and the Mongols are frightened
and
Jesse who later became my vice president
in Los Angeles when I took over the club
down there and uh later became a Hell's
Angel here in Ventura
fell down this big Mongol hit him and he
fell down and he I kind of looked out of
the corner of my eye and
he had his arms spread out and I
there was a motor sprocket gear there
and motor sprockets are about this big
with spikes on it and a hole in the
center he hooked it on his hand he
jumped up and he just started hacking
people and there was blood and flesh
flying and people screaming and you know
everybody fighting and in the middle of
all this
imagine a young
scared police officer uniform police
officer there was one you said and a
police officer one
one uniform for the whole event you know
this is
1976 or 77. so one uniformed officer and
he comes in and he's got his revolver
drawn now he's only got six shots he's
got a revolver you know service revolver
and he's yelling at everybody and we're
all looking at each other
and this gun looks about this big of
course did he put it did he put a stop
to it first yeah yeah yeah it stopped
yeah everybody stopped and so the when
they when we stopped the Mongols broke
and I'm not saying they broke and ran
because they were scared because these
guys weren't scared uh it they stopped
they broke and ran we broke and ran
and
so everybody's getting away you know and
uh I uh I ran out and there was a Mongol
the fight had stopped now and there was
a Mongol and he goes what the hell's
going on he's like yelling at me and
there's like the cops started kind of
there was more cops like starting to
come around I don't know if they were
outside or what that happened so fast
and I said you don't know what's going
on you know this I'm young you know I'm
a Hell's Angel and I'm in my 20s and I
think I'm cool and I go you know what's
going on he goes no what's going on and
I go this is what's going on and I
smacked it and we started fighting and
the cops started beating on us both of
us with the club and the same slaves who
were like I you know I came that close
to becoming a saint rather than a Hell's
Angel I was so close with those guys
they got around the cop and they said
don't hit that Hell's Angel they're
gonna hit the Mongol and so the cops for
whatever reason turned and started his
Mongol the same slaves grabbed me and
these guys were all like six one six two
big dudes and uh carried me out of there
the rest of the Hell's Angels were there
there was like six of us on bikes it was
like nine of us there and we were all
started laughing hysterically and uh we
jumped on our bikes kicked our bikes
over you know no electric starters back
then kicked our bikes over and we ran
out of that place man I felt like I was
in the James gang we just robbed a bank
we're laughing and uh so we get back to
the clubhouse in Glendale
and old man John's already heard about
the fight and old man John 6 4
big hands and he always had a cigar in
his mouth and it was always half smoked
and he always chomped on it when he was
talking to bounce up and down
what the hell is going on out there and
he takes it out of his mouth and we're
going well John
got in a fight you know I know you got
in a goddamn fight you know what he's
going on and on and uh
but he didn't what he was mad at you
never guess what he was mad at John that
those guys the Mongols had the nerve to
lay a hand on us he wasn't mad at us we
started the fight but he wasn't mad at
us he was mad because they laid a hand
on us and so he ran in the house
comes out with a pump shotgun he had
this old Ford Mustang I don't know what
year it was it was an old one faded
paint you know uh it was a rag top I
remember the top being all you know just
and he opened the trunk up and he's
smoking on the cigar and he throws a
shotgun and he tells
who is going to become the guy that was
eventually murdered who's going to
become the new Hell's Angel president in
Los Angeles because you go with me and
uh
why'd he pick him I don't know uh and
I'll tell you another thing John used to
tell me in uh
make a lot of sense to you I didn't ask
John because John told me one time
because you want to last in this
business quit asking questions I said
okay fair enough and so I didn't ask
questions but I said I did confront him
I said hey John
don't you think it'd be better to let
them Brew on the fight
and they'll wonder what's going to be
next and then we can petition you know
for a sit down because what I mean
John's idea was just goes out and he
told me and he already told me what
new guy get your ass in the clubhouse I
went back in the clubhouse and he took
off with Bray and you know Jesse and I
were uh in the clubhouse Jesse you know
was the guy with the motor sprocket
you know we just sat in there all night
you know waiting for John then John we
see the headlights rolling in the
driveway and he had resolved it
but uh you know I felt
and I respectfully told him uh alone I
never questioned him in front of anybody
I said man I think it would have been
smarter from a military standpoint to
wait and let them Brew on what was going
to come next and then petition them
you know John John didn't care you know
and John didn't care about anything you
know all John cared about was us we were
his family and uh you know he was a real
old school guy you know he'd tell you
one time he took me to a fight with
another bike club I didn't even know you
know you didn't ask back to what we were
doing
[Music]